I'm happy to do that and and you know of
course to bring my young bride along to
kind of educate her as to what's to come
with us senior citizens it was a date
night Monday for Michael Douglas and
Catherine zeta-jones the pair stepped
out for the double ARP of movies for
grown-ups event where Michael was being
honored Michael and Catherine also went
out the night before hitting up at Super
Bowl 50 in style it's always so great
it's just yeah I mean I'm a sports fan
because of my husband because I have no
choice but I do i do love sports
genuinely I do but it's been a bit of a
date for us we go to the Super Bowl and
we have a great great time
nice Americana it's something entirely
unique especially for Catherine coming
from Wales
they don't have football too much sure
my our kind over there so it was a
lovely we had a great day great dad talk
about a cool couple
well unless you ask their kids 15
year-old Dylan and 12 year olds Terrace
they think we're very dumb right now and
then they'll grow up and go boy they
learn quick